que peut-on faire avec cette pipe alors
on se la met entre les dents comme biens
fictifs et le calumet électroniques ont
slamé entre les dents et elle sert à
écouter la radio
puisqu'elle contient dans le fourneau de
la pipe un mini récepteur de radio avec
son amplification sa patrie de piles et
l'écouteur est remplacé par un
fume-cigarette relié à un vibrateur ce
sont les dents qui transmettent à
l'oreille interne sans que les sons et à
passer par le tapant et par laurie
moyenne on peut imaginer que dans un
repas officiel ou familial où on
s'ennuie qu'on ait envie d'écouter les
résultats des courses et qu'on puisse
écouter ses émissions en broche 700
postes et on a l'air d'être des la
fumeurs river le feu et en fait on
écoute la radio
non je vous assure c'est la vérité trace
un incroyable mais pourtant vrai c'est
le plus gros opérateur japonais qui est
à l'origine de cette invention
son principe un téléphone bracelet un
peu comme ceux ci mais ce mobile n'aura
ni haut parleurs ni oreillettes la
communication passera par le doigt sous
forme de vibrations pour accrocher il
suffira de presser le pouce contre
l'index et plus de clavier non plus la
numérotation se fera à la voix de
science fiction comme ça mais oui où les
envahisseurs je sais pas qu'est ce que
vous en pensez vous d'un téléphone ou
n'auraient le doigt dans l'oreille comme
ça on est un peu l'air d'un con nous
sommes pas un peu bizarre quand même le
doigt dans l'oreille mais pas ça des
fois ça n'est pas si c'est un truc
nouvelle génération mais il reste alors
une autre inconnue pour cette
technologie
car que se passera-t-il en cas de double
appel